vor einiger zeit haben wir ein video
gemacht mit werben die das präfix fähre
haben und dieses video seht ihr hier
oben und nach diesem video haben uns
immer wieder leute geschrieben macht
doch mal bitte auch videos mit werben
die andere präfix zu haben und darum
geht es im heutigen video umwerben mit
dem präfix sie werben mit dem präfix c
sind immer untrennbar
also sie werden immer zusammen
geschrieben in jeglicher form und dieses
kleine präfix er das hat keine direkte
übersetzung also man kann das nicht mit
einem einzigen wort übersetzen denn
dieses präfix ist schon sehr alt in der
deutschen sprache und hat heute keine
direkte übersetzung mehr
allerdings gibt es eine art gefühl oder
ein bild das man immer hat wenn man
diese werben hört und dieses bild ist
das etwas ganzes in viele kleine teile
zerfällt oder etwas kaputt gemacht wird
oder etwas getrennt wird also das hört
man auch bei vielen werben zum beispiel
zerstören zerreißen zerrütten es geht
irgendwie immer etwas kaputt wenn ihr
genau mehr wissen möchtet oder die
genaue bedeutung wissen möchte von
diesem präfix dann könnt ihr einen
schönen artikel dazu lesen bei unserem
freund emanuel den verlinken wir mal
hier unten und jetzt zeigen wir euch ein
paar beispiele mit janosch die euch das
ganze nochmal veranschaulichen
sehr reißen janisch reißt den karton
er hat jetzt einmal gerissen aber wenn
man ganz oft reißt bis alles ganz klein
ist und fast nichts mehr da ist dann
sagt man auch zerreißen janisch hat den
karton zerrissen vertreten
janosch tritt den karton
[Musik]
das war jetzt ein normales treten
harnisch hat den karton g treten
jetzt zeigt euch janisch was zertreten
bedeutet vertreten heißt wann tritt so
lange auf dem karton herum bis der
karton in seiner ursprünglichen form
nicht mehr existiert deutsche machen das
zum beispiel damit dass schön in die
mülltonne passt und wann platz gespart
hat sehr gut janosch zerkleinern janisch
zerkleinert die walnüsse wenn man etwas
zerkleinert dann macht man etwas sehr
sehr klein
man kann auch das verb verkleinern
benutzen aber wenn man etwas verkleinert
dann existiert das später noch in einer
kleineren form sehr kleiner heißt so
etwas wie das was man zerkleinert hat
ist in der ursprünglichen form nicht
mehr da jetzt haben wir eine
zerkleinerte walnuss lecker die amish
möchte zitronensaft haben
janosch zerquetscht die zitrone
hmm
man kann auch sagen janisch zermatscht
die zitrone
wenn es danach matschie ist übrigens
wenn ihr noch mehr deutsche grammatik
lernen wollt dann könnt ihr das am
besten ganz systematisch in unserer app
sieht lang tun
dort stellen wir euch nämlich kleine
grammatik einheiten immer in kleinen
geschichten vor
viele davon auch mit jahren von mir und
anderen freunden von easy german guckt
euch das mal an und da könnt ihr schritt
für schritt die deutsche grammatik in
kleinen geschichten lernen
janosch hat sich ships gekauft jetzt
zeigt ihr euch was er mit diesen chips
man kann
janosch verteilt einen chip janosch sehr
drückt einen chip janisch zerbröselt
einen chip das heißt er macht daraus
ganz viele kleine brösel janisch ist
eine schöpfung wenn er im mund ist man
kaut man und wenn man etwas so lange
gekauft hat dass es nicht mehr da ist
dann ist es auch sehr kaut janus lässt
die tasse fallen die tasse zerbricht
nein die tasse ist zerbrochen
die amish muss alles wieder aufheben
das war unser video zum thema werben mit
ca und wir hoffen dass wir jetzt ein
bisschen besser verstanden habe was
dieses kleine präfix bedeutet und in
welchem kontext es immer benutzt wird
wenn ihr noch mehr lernen wollt dann
guckt euch unbedingt unsere app ceiling
an und wir werden natürlich in zukunft
noch mehr werben mit pre fixen in
unseren videos thematisieren
tschüss und bis bald
[Musik]